trois ans identique de suppressions sont
en discussion commune le 15 monsieur
loïc hervé merci monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres s'est pris dans
la commission des lois monsieur leur
apportant chers collègues alors je ne
connais aucun des efforts qui ont été
ceux de notre rapporteur pour trouver
une rédaction bien meilleure beaucoup
plus robuste juridiquement et qui
permettent de mieux encadrer se passait
et terre pour autant jean je demeure
convaincu que cette idée de mettre en
place un pass à lire dans notre pays est
une mauvaise idée
et ce pour plusieurs raisons la première
c'est que nous créons un précédent sans
doute pour une des premières fois dans
notre histoire nationale nous allons
pour l'exercice de libertés publiques du
quotidien devoir justifier de notre état
de santé
mais ça mais chacun j'attire votre
attention parce que c'est quelque chose
qui n'existait pas et là que vides ne
peut pas être seulement une malédiction
qui fait reculer les libertés et ceux
qui pensent que le pass sanitaire va
nous permettre de reconquérir des
libertés de mon point de vue ce troupes
puisque le pas salutaire est une
nouvelle contrainte deuxième
deuxième raison de mon opposition c'est
des réserves quant à aux personnes qui
vont être en capacité de mener les
contrôles dans notre pays le port sur
soi-même d'un document d'identité n'est
absolument pas obligatoire
il ya d'autres pays on est dans l'union
européenne où c'est le cas à la suisse
par exemple
mais dans le pays ça n'est pas le cas et
vous devrez justifier de votre état de
santé
justifier de votre identité le lieu à
d'un contrat c'est à dire la vente d'un
d'un ticket de deux spectacles par
exemple et donc ça pose une vraie
difficulté et enfin le la plus
grande de mes craintes c'est le risque
de généralisation dans cet hémicycle
personne ne sait où nous en serons le 15
septembre
en terme de situation sanitaire pourvu
qu un mutant qu'un variant une quatrième
vague que je ne sais quel encore
calamité nous tombe sur le coin de la
tête
et à ce moment là nos finances publiques
nous permettrons pas de faire un nouveau
confinement et on aura entre les mains
litim formidable qui nous permettra de
ne pas confiner le pass sanitaires donc
quand on nous promet aujourd'hui que
jamais il ne sera généralisé à partir du
moment où il existe le danger sera là et
il pourra l'être et à ce moment là nous
aurons basculer dans une société de
surveillance généralisée mais c'est
l'abondance 16 à rectifier
madame sylvia noël oui je vous en prie
sa collègue
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
l'article premier définit un régime de
sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
applicable à partir du 1er juillet
jusqu'au 15 septembre
reprenant les bases établies par la loi
du 9 juillet 2020 ce projet de loi ne
nous propose pas en réalité de sortir de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire il vient en
réalité diminuée l'esprit les libertés
publiques par rapport à la première
version du texte et s'assimile sur de
nombreux aspects à la mise en oeuvre
d'un état d'urgence permanent
il convient de rappeler que si le projet
de loi semble acté la sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire au 1er juin 2021
la loi du 15 février 2021 permet
toujours aux gouvernements de réactiver
par simple décret l'état d'urgence
sanitaire jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 mais
surtout l'article premier vient signer
la création du passeport sanitaires or
bien que ce passeport sanitaire était
habilement présentée comme un moyen
d'exercer notre liberté de circulation
il représente une ingérence inédite dans
nos libertés fondamentales car il
conduit directement à imposer à
l'immense majorité des citoyens soit un
vaccin dont le gouvernement affirme
pourtant qu'il ne sera jamais
obligatoire soit d'innombrables test de
dépistage a présenté à de multiples
occasions de nos vies
collectivités alors que les tests pcr ne
sont pas et n'ont jamais été utilisées
comme un outil de diagnostic et leur
validité en tant qu outil diagnostique a
même été remise en cause par l' oms il
n'ya donc à ce jour aucun motif valable
pour justifier la mise en place de ce
passeport sanitaires permettant ainsi
ouvertement la discrimination en créant
une catégorie de citoyens de seconde
zone
ainsi se dessine avec ce projet une
société d'apartheid où des citoyens bien
portants seront mis au ban de la société
cela inacceptable et je crains comme mon
collègue que nous mettions le doigt dans
un engrenage très dangereux pour nos
libertés fondamentales
je vous invite donc mes chers collègues
a rejeté cet article merci
et madame la présidente assassi pour le
oui merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues donc c'est à cet
amendement de suppression de l'article
premier confirme notre position à ce
nouveau régime juridique de sortie de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire pour les
raisons que j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
d'expliciter dans la présentation de
notre question préalable
ce nouveau régime juridique est une
véritable zone grise entre le droit
commun et l'état d'urgence et ce qui
permettra au gouvernement de continuer à
disposer de larges pouvoirs de police
administrative certes il ne pourra
interdire aux personnes de sortir de
leur domicile comme sous l'état
d'urgence mais il pourra toujours
interdire la circulation des personnes
et laissé le couvre feu se poursuivre
jusqu'au 30 juin suite à un amendement
du gouvernement adopté en commission
c'est ce régime plus que bancale
juridiquement qui a conduit la
commission des lois repoussait la fin de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire au 30 juin
prochain nous n'y sommes pas favorables
comme ne sommes pas favorables à la
prolongation du couvre-feu aucune preuve
sérieuse l'utilité de ce couvre-feu n'a
été apportée quel message adressez nous
à nos concitoyennes et à nos concitoyens
si dans un projet censé organiser la
sortie de crise nous prorogeant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
le message n'est certainement pas plus
confus que celui du gouvernement mais il
n'est pas moins trompeur en outre au
sein de cet article le gouvernement a
donc fait adopter par voie d'amendement
en commission à l'assemblée nationale
une mesure que je qualifierais
d'original
cette fois c'est à dire celle visant à
mettre en oeuvre à part sanitaires sur
le territoire national ce véhicule
législatif a permis au gouvernement de
se passer de l'avis du conseil d'état et
sur le sujet et d'une étude d'impact
détaillées sur l'outil qui est proposé
ce qui apparaît assez pratique
étant donné le nombre de questions qui
restent en suspens quant à la mise en
place de ce parce qu'elle contrôle sera
effectué par qui quel en sera le support
qu'elle conservation des données et
enfin ne se dirige-t-on pas vers une
obligation tacite de la vaccination
je vous le redis et tel était le sens de
ma de la question préalable ouzou nous
nous opposons aux réponses autoritaire
du gouvernement sur des questions aussi
importantes et à la gestion de cette
crise par un enchevêtrement à seissan
des lois d'exception dictée par une
conception que je calque que je
qualifierais aussi de verticale du
pouvoir et qui me semble être nuisible à
notre démocratie
m'est avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur les trois amendements
identiques
mes chers collègues
faisons attention tout de même parce que
refuser d'articles premier parce qu'on
est au stylo au pass sanitaires
c'est abandonner aussi des dispositions
sans lesquels il n'y a plus
de réglementation possible pour protéger
les français contre les contaminations à
partir du jour où serait promulguée la
loi
le pass sanitaires ces 9 alinéa sur les
27 de l'article 1er c'est un premier
point les journalistes d'irène ne jetons
pas le bébé avec l'eau du bain
bon mais s'agissant du bébé parlons-en
tout de même nous avons considéré qu'il
était mal formés et nous avons dans les
délibérations de la commission des lois
apporter un certain nombre de garanties
aux régimes de ce pass sanitaires
parfois on raisonne comme s'il
s'agissait d' entraver des événements ou
des manifestations qui serait
aujourd'hui parfaitement libres en
faisant un filtrage en fonction du pass
sanitaires ça n'est pas du tout la
manière dont la réalité se présente
la réalité c'est que ce sont des
événements qui sont aujourd'hui
interdits et peuvent continuer à l'être
donc le pass sanitaire n'est pas un
instrument qui viendraient restreindre
des libertés par rapport à la situation
actuelle ici et maintenant
c'est un instrument qui permettra au
contraire d'assouplir des interdits qui
aujourd'hui sont radicaux j'entends bien
un argument auquel je suis moi-même
sensible parce que je ne me suis pas
engagée à proposer des solutions que
j'ai proposées à la commission sans
mettre profondément interrogé sur ce
texte
c'est l'argument du précédent ce serait
la première fois qu'on subordonnerait
l'accès à un événement à une
manifestation un lieu quelconque à une
information de santé
et c'est vrai mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons veillé d'une part à
restreindre très strictement dans le
temps la possibilité de mettre en oeuvre
le pass sanitaire je crois que ça c'est
très important
il tombera à la date du 15 septembre mme
si notre texte est adopté
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle nous
avons prévu des sanctions pénales
lourdes pour toute personne qui
exigerait le pass sanitaire en dehors
des conditions prévues par notre texte
et ça je crois que c'est important aussi
et le pass sanitaire ne serait
applicable qu avec un décret en conseil
d'état qui fixerait toutes les garanties
nécessaires et seulement pour des lieux
qui par leur configuration par leur
nature même seraient des lieux ou sans
le pass sanitaires l'autorité sanitaire
seraient obligés d'interdire la
manifestation et je reviens beaucoup sur
ce point au fond si nous nous plaçons
dans la situation de lever par paliers
successifs toutes les entraves aux
libertés
alors c'est un sas utile que de mettre
en oeuvre ce pass sanitaire en veillant
bien naturellement à ce que les
personnes soient habilitées à le
contrôler et que l'autorité
administrative remplissent pleinement sa
fonction
donc mes chers collègues la commission
émet un avis défavorable à ces
amendements mais elle rejoint les
préoccupations qui vous ont motivé en
posant des garanties et elle préserve ce
faisant le reste de l'article 1er qui
est tout de même bien utile nous avons
sénat de la république une
responsabilité vis-à-vis des français
nous sommes une assemblée libre et
indépendante et non alignés et la seule
assemblée
je pense en ce moment où le débat peut
déboucher sur une transformation réelle
de la loi cette transformation de la loi
nous vous la proposons essayons
d'assumer notre responsabilité qui
consistent tout de même à ne pas trop
baisser la garde dans la lutte contre le
coc vie de 19 en nous donnant les moyens
de cette sortie progressive de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
merci monsieur le rapporteur avait du
gouvernement
oui messieurs le président est
rapidement pour ne pas abuser de votre
patience
quelques éléments en complément rapide
de ce que vient de dire monsieur le
rapporteur d'abord en répandant à madame
noël que je me vois plus en tout cas
pour dire que oui il y a des
soubassements sanitaire au déploiement
du du pass sanitaires et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui conduit l'ensemble des
pays européens à faire de même
il est effectif monsieur loïc caraveilhe
de saint-hervé que nous créons un
précédent d'une certaine manière c'est
ce que nous faisons depuis quelques mois
et voir un an en essayant d'avoir le
meilleur équilibre possible entre
sécurité et régulation ce qui n'est pas
tout le temps facile mais nous essayons
d'être le plus équilibré possible et
c'est pour cette raison que nous ne
faisons pas le même choix que certain
nombre de nos pays européens c'est à
dire que nous ne le faisons pas pour le
quotidien nous ne le faisons pas pour
les courses ne le faisons pas pour les
restaurants nous ne le faisons pas en
référence à une circonscription commune
avec la sénatrice noël pour la
chartreuse du reposoir en tout cas pour
tous ces éléments qui effectivement
irait probablement trop loin en tout cas
sur cette question de la liberté
je pense que cette question est un peu
plus complexe que cela d'autres pays
européens ou au nom même de la liberté
et si vous regardez les débats ont
préféré déployer se passe plutôt qu'un
confinement ou plutôt qu'un couvre-feu
et donc
on peut avoir une acception différente
de cette question de la liberté et il
s'agit en tout cas d'essayer de trouver
un juste un juste milieu je répète par
ailleurs que oui on demandera la carte
d'identité pour des raisons logiques
mais qu'on le fait par ailleurs lorsque
normalement vous acheter de l'alcool et
que vous êtes jeune lorsque vous êtes
dans un train ou que vous prenez un
métro il peut y avoir une vérification
de carte d'identité de la même manière
chez un buraliste si vous allez jouer à
chaque fois c'est une question de
proportion et c'est ce que nous essayons
de trouver là encore donc avis
défavorable du gouvernement jamais vu
fabien avant de donner la parole pour
les explications de vote je vous demande
de vous préparer j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
l'est républicain sur les trois
amendements qui nous sont soumis alors
explications de vote
monsieur laurent duplomb
oui monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres moi je vais soutenir
l'amendement de sylviane noël comme
d'hervé de loïc hervé je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ce système qui
consisterait à nous dire que sans arrêt
nous sommes obligés de contraindre un
peu plus notre population
je pense que le jour où on va accepter
se passe comme loïc l'a dit ça sera
d'accepter que plus loin comme le
tyrolien sur une échelle
on craint que les éléments et à chaque
fois on en rajoute
on l'a vu depuis un an on est passé par
il n'est pas nécessaire de porter le
masque dans la bouche du ministre de la
santé
et aujourd'hui vous avez tous un masque
même ceux qui sont vaccinées il faudrait
un pass pour ceux qui sont vaccinées
mais il faudra quand même qui porte le
masque mais on est sur des paradoxes qui
sont complètement hallucinant et on
continue comme si avec une voiture où il
n'y ait plus de feu plus de phares plus
rien du tout on continue de rouler même
si en face de nous on sait que le muret
en face c'était hallucinant on est
exactement sur le même sujet sur les
tests sérologiques quand on disait qu'il
fallait atteindre l'immunité collective
il y avait deux façons d'atteindre
l'immunité collective vacciner monsieur
le ministre très rapidement avec 250
milles praticiens entre les docteurs
généralistes et les pharmaciens quatre
vaccins par jour pour chacun c'était un
million de vaccinés tous les jours on
n'est pas à 20 millions de vaccinés on
est à peine à 10 millions de vaccinés
puisque normalement la vaccination ces
deux doses 6 mai chez les chiffres que
j'ai retenus sont bons et que le test
sérologique qui permettait d'apporter
une forme de 2,2 d'explications sur le
principe de dire ceux qui ont eu la
maladie ont un test sérologique positif
et donc ne sont plus contraints par la
maladie on n'a jamais accepté depuis un
an de faire que ces tests sérologiques
soit reconnu et là comme par
enchantement avec le past avec le
passent le test sérologique peut
apporter
le principe d'un dans le pass le
deuxième est le dernier élément c'est
que c'est ce que je disais une fois
qu'on aura accepté se passe on
l'acceptera pour tous et un moment donné
on nous dira qu'avec se passe parce
qu'on ne peut plus confiné parce qu'on
ne peut plus faire ci ou parce qu'on ne
peut plus faire ça eh bien on triera les
français on aura des français de
première zone et des français de seconde
zone
alors on connaissait déjà suffisamment
ça entre le milieu urbain et le milieu
rural
je pense qu'il a pas besoin d'en
rajouter donc c'est pour ça que je
soutiendrai ses amendements et bien dit
dans monsieur le ministre je soutiendrai
mes trois collègues
on ne peut en même temps prétendre que
chacun a sa liberté ou non de se
vacciner est subordonné l'accès aux e
harper ou à certaines manifestations
impasse sanitaire qui en réalité est un
pass vaccinale qui ne dit pas son nom
on peut jouer sur les mots mais dès que
l'on soumet la liberté circuler à
l'obtention d'un document d'une piqûre
ou d'un test cela s'appelle un laisser
passer cela sous-entend donc une
obligation celle de se vacciner
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions
monsieur le ministre de la santé oms ne
peuvent faire le bonheur des gens contre
leur gré ni régenter la circulation de
nos concitoyens pour préserver une
gestion catastrophique des services de
réanimation des hôpitaux
vous nous rendez une liberté mais c'est
une liberté conditionnelle
les confinements les attestations de
sortie absurde les autotests résultats
aléatoires sont le terreau d'une dune
d'un système de surveillance globale de
la population
si l'exaspération de nos concitoyens
mettait au pouvoir un parti extrémiste
il aura déjà en main tous les outils
d'un état autoritaire et c'est vous qui
l'aurait forget monsieur bah a évoqué
l'article 1er il est vrai que
le pass annie terre prend en otage
l'article 1er est notre ami loïc hervé a
parlé d'un précédent puis vous créer un
précédent
un précédent qui n'a pas de fondement
scientifique et qui sacralise la
certitude la servitude volontaire merci
merci la parole est à madame millions
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres chers collègues je vais
prendre l'exemple des parcs de loisirs
la décision d'instaurer un pass
sanitaires à l'ensemble de la filière
française de loisirs sans tenir compte
des spécificités du secteur serait
extrêmement préjudiciable à la
réouverture des parcs de loisirs
ces derniers étant fortement contraint
par les jauges prévues dans le cadre du
projet de loi serait de surcroît soumis
aux difficultés de mise en place de ce
pass sanitaire fortement dissuasif pour
les visiteurs potentiels
l'application d'une telle mesure n'est
ni nécessaire ni adapté dans les parcs
de loisirs et risque de mettre en danger
la reprise touristique de notre
territoire les inégalités régionales
d'accès pour disposer d'un pass
sanitaire produirait des discriminations
importantes entre visiteurs ainsi
qu'entre types d'établissements
concernés par cette mesure
la localisation de nombreux parcs
souvent en zones périurbaines ou rurales
où l'offre de test est relativement
réduite rendra difficile aux visiteurs
jeunes et donc non vaccinés la
production de ce test négatif je pense
forcément l'exemple du parc du
puy-du-fou en vendée où il yad'autres à
3 millions de visiteurs chaque été par
ailleurs le past sanitaire est également
inapplicable en l'état aux structures de
la filière qui ne dispose ni des
compétences techniques pour apprécier la
validité de la conformité des
informations qui seront présentées ni
des pouvoirs de police permettant un
contrôle systématiser de l'identité des
visiteurs permettant de vérifier la
concordance des informations médicales
présentées il crée par ailleurs en
france une rupture d'égalité et une
concurrence déloyale entre les
différents acteurs du tourisme puisque
d'autres lieux de tourisme et de loisirs
ni son al'inverse pas soumis
même si impliquant de grands
rassemblements
deux personnes durant l'été 2020 les
protocoles sanitaires instauré en accord
avec les préfectures avait permis de
garantir la sécurité de tous à notre
connaissance la fréquentation des parcs
de loisirs à cette époque avec les
mesures de prévention en vigueur n'a pas
été à l'origine de clusters ou de
contamination massive ce qui interroge
par conséquent sur la nécessité
d'inclure ces structures le plus souvent
situés en extérieur enfin ils risquent
d'entraîner un déclassement de la
destination touristique france face à
des voisins européens ou le pass
sanitaire n'est pas exigée pour les
activités de loisirs
donc finalement se passe sanitaire
appliquée au parc de loisirs c'est
l'illusion d'une bulle sanitaire parks
que ni les salariés ni les employés ni
les bénévoles ni les fournisseurs ni les
soutes restant n'auront besoin de ce
pass sanitaires sur les parcs de loisirs
pour toutes ces raisons concrètes
les trois amendements très bien merci à
chacun de rester dans le temps de parole
et pas au delà la parole est à monsieur
savoldelli oui merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues le
ministre
moi je suis bien écouté nos collègues
noël hervé et ma présidente eliane
assassi j'ai vu aucune réponse de votre
part monsieur le ministre il faut
comprendre que l'ensemble des élus ici
vous demandent des critères clairs et
précis et je vais dire pourquoi parce
qu'il faut dire toute la vérité vous
aviez prévu de mettre en place votre f
data aube pour appeler vous connaissez
ça c'est les données de santé qui sont
considérés par la réglementation comme
des données de santé au même titre que
l'appartenance syndicale la religion
elles font l'objet d'un encadrement au
regard du risque qu'elles peuvent avoir
d'utilisation vous aviez envisagé au
départ ça avant de reculer grâce à
l'intervention de parlementaires mais
grâce aussi à l'opinion publique
française
je rappelle à mes collègues c'est une
plate forme importante l'ensemble des
données permet la reconstruction des
parcours de santé de 67 millions de
personnes chaud près de 12 années ça
c'était votre projet politique initiale
qui n'a rien à voir avec la situation
temporaire extrêmement grave de la
situation avec le co vide qu'était un
autre projet qui porte atteinte à nos
libertés
j'ai même chercher il y avait tout dans
la prise en charge médicale par la sécu
mais il y avait les visites médicales
scolaire les visites santé au travail
voyez l'enjeu est pas minime et c'est
pour ça que si vous vous rappelez bien
le conseil d'état s'est prononcé
leyrit a eu des observations de l'acte
il donc moi vraiment je soutiens les
trois interventions elles sont à la fois
différente mais complémentaire de mes
trois collègues hervé noël et ma
présidente assassi et je regrette que
les réponses et était très évasive
merci merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président je n'ai jamais
ménagé mes critiques sur la politique de
gestion de crise sanitaire du
gouvernement est ici
quelles que soient les manches personne
ne peut m'accuser de connivence ou de
complicité avec le gouvernement mais je
voudrais vous expliquer pourquoi je vais
soutenir la position du rapporteur
philippe bas la position aussi la
commission des lois
premier argument qui pourrait être
important c'est que la stratégie de la
france pour venir à bout de la pandémie
ça doit être une stratégie hybride une
vaccination massive et sans doute
faudra-t-il ouvrir encore plus avec les
libéraux
mais aussi pour les publics pour les
jeunes qui fréquentent effectivement les
festivals puisqu'on sait désormais que
le vaccin bloquent la transmission une
vaccination massive
ensuite ne pas abandonner l'autre part
de stratégie qui est de casser les
chaînes de contamination vous et moi on
a lu dans un certain nombre de revues
sérieuse les prises de position de ceux
qui sont pour une stratégie coville 0 ou
pour une stratégie vaccination je pense
que c'est un faux débat et je pense que
c'est la stratégie hybride qui est la
bonne et par conséquent casser les
chaînes de contamination je suis désolé
ça passe aussi par le pass sanitaire
première chose
deuxième élément la sécurité la liberté
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure des
arguments qui consiste à dire que on
créerait des citoyens de deuxième zone
est ce qu'un maire est ce qu'un maire
lorsque ils refusent la scolarisation
d'un enfant qui n'a pas de certification
notamment pour la vaccination de
rougeole est ce que le maire créé dans
sa commune des citoyens de seconde zone
la liberté la sécurité sont liés c'est
la sécurité qui est d'ailleurs la
condition de notre liberté
c'est un débat qu'on a connu aussi avec
le terrorisme et enfin compte tenu de ce
que nous dit le gouvernement
c'est à dire un dispositif exceptionnel
et temporaire
compte tenu de la sécurisation qu'ont
fait nos collègues députés avec en
excluant tous les actes de la vie
quotidienne
et je rajoute les garanties apportées
par notre commission des lois je pense
qu en mon âme et conscience et
pardonnez-moi les collègues de
différents bords y compris d'ailleurs de
mon propre groupe
je soutiendrai la position de notre
commission des lois et je voterai contre
ces trois amendements de suppression
merci je vous signale que nous avons
encore plusieurs intervenantes donc
vraiment que chacun respecte les temps
maintenant ça s'appelle les débats mais
si chacun respecte les règles qui sont
celles du temps naturellement il madame
la présidente à ça si justement
président fait moi je voulais répondre à
une partie de la vie qui a été rendu par
notre rapporteur sur ces amendements de
suppression il nous dit qu'il n'ya pas
que l'article 1er ne se limite pas à la
question du pass sanitaires on est
d'accord on a travaillé il ya 27 alinéa
dans cet article on sait mais monsieur
le rapporteur mais ça vaut aussi pour
messieurs les ministres
on peut quand même s'interroger sur les
raison et là haut je m'adresse aussi au
président et ayo sur les raisons qui ont
amené le gouvernement à introduire se
passe a dit terre dans l'article 1er en
commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale le passage du ter après tout
aurait pu faire l'objet d'un article à
lui tout seul ce qui n'est pas le cas
donc ouais je crois sincèrement
sincèrement je pense que la ficelle est
un peu grosse d'autant que je pense que
le gouvernement s'attendait à un débat
binaire sur ce sujet or il n'est pas
binaire il est transverse on le voit
bien aujourd'hui ils traversent tous les
bancs de notre de l'autre et missiles
dont je répète
la ficelle est un peu grosse en
substance si on refuse pas sanitaires on
refuserait de sortir de l'état de l'état
d'urgence ce qui selon monsieur le
rapporteur ne serait pas sérieux
mais monsieur le rapporteur c'est la
méthode utilisée qui n'est pas sérieuse
et pour le coup ce n'est pas un
précédent merci la parole est à mme
benarroch pardon
c'est un collègue j'aurais aimé comme
beaucoup ici parmi vous je pose pourra
voter sur un texte aux conséquences
mieux connu plus conformes aux alertes
de la cnil
parce que je comprends bien comme l'a
dit la présidente assassi que derrière
cet article là qui mélange à la fois le
fasse a ni terre et d'autres mesures
on essaye de nous faire voter un
ensemble et que nous même avoir des
difficultés à nous positionner parce que
nous ne sommes pas forcément pour ce pas
sanitaire mais néanmoins grâce au
travail la commission des lois et à son
et à son rapporteur
nous avons amélioré un certain nombre de
points substantiellement de cet article
1er néanmoins il est vrai que quand on
pose une question simple simpliste même
dirais-je qui consiste à dire c'est pas
sanitaires ou pas de concert la plupart
d'entre nous disent eh bien pour les
copeaux l'activité économique pour le
bien-être psychologique pour l'activité
culturelle et ben mettant le pass
sanitaire parce que comme ça il y aura
des concerts mais je pense que c'est une
mauvaise façon de poser cette question
aux fêtes
parce qu'en fait quand on parle de
passer ni terre de quoi parlons nous
concrètement quelles sont les données
personnelles que nous allons devoir
partager
jusqu'où devrons-nous aller pour obtenir
un qr dits valides
est-ce que simple bénévole d'une
association à l'autre et d'un événement
qui serait soumis à l'obtention du pass
sanitaire pourra contrôler ces données
pour a conféré une légitimité d'entrée
ou de pas entrer dans cet événement
quelle responsabilité prendra-t-il lors
de refus de ce pass and i ter qu'elles
sont en gros quels sont tous les
éléments qui permettent de faire que
actuellement se passer ni terre puis
servir que deuxièmement ils puissent ne
pas être prolongé vous savez qu'on a
l'état d'urgence a été prolongé deux
fois alors le pas sanitaire pourra
l'être également et pourra-t-il être
utilisé pour d'autres raisons et
d'autres virus que le convive 19 dans
d'autres circonstances
notre collègue loïc hervé l'a bien dit
et a bien pointé tous les risques qui se
pourrait se poser sur l'utilisation de
ce pass sanitaires
donc nous sommes partagés en ce qui me
concerne personnellement et ça n'engage
pas le groupe je voterai pour les
abonnements je voterai donc contre le
pass sanitaire même si je suis conscient
que dans l'arctique premier figure un
certain nombre d'autres éléments qui
auraient pu être utiles merci la parole
est à madame tempo lyon
que le président je crois que ce débat
est un peu long mais il est absolument
essentiel parce que nous touchons là
effectivement quand même à des questions
à des questions éthiques à des questions
philosophiques à des questions profondes
par rapport à notre société aux libertés
qui sont qui sont les nôtres et à la
façon dont nous pouvons gérer cette
crise pour ma part je considère que nous
pouvons rentrer dans l'engrenage proposé
par le pass sanitaires et finalement je
reprendrai l'argument qui a été posée
par le rapporteur
en dix ans mais finalement ce pass
sanitaire ce n'est pas une restriction
ce serait une possibilité d'ouvrir de
nouvelles
de nouvelles hausses de nouveau droit
d'accéder à telle ou telle chose qu'ici
nous ne mettons pas en place n'aurait
pas lieu
mais vous imaginez imaginons nous quelle
pression nous allons nous mettre
collectivement sur les sur les épaules
si tant est que la crise perdure si tant
est que nous soyons obligés de faire
durer telle ou telle restriction plus
longtemps à ce moment là les
professionnels de telle profession les
bénévoles de tels types d'associations
nous diront mais c'est simple vous
n'avez déjà mis en place
pourquoi nous permettez vous pas de
reprendre notre activité pourquoi ne
permettez vous pas de faire vivre notre
tissu économique pourquoi pourquoi et
que répondront nous ne pourrons rien
répondre du roi mais là en fait là on
pouvait mais maintenant on peut plus non
il s'agit là d'une question de principe
c'est à dire de se dire un moment donné
est ce que oui ou non on met en place
une un état sur la base de l'état de
santé une rupture vis-à-vis du principe
d'égalité
je crois que en âme et conscience en
tout cas tout à fait personnellement je
ne peut valider cette option et je crois
que effectivement ce débat il est
important il traverse finalement
l'engagement de chacun il ya sur surtout
nos bancs des gens qui s'interrogent
je crois que c'est important
effectivement que nous puissions en est
changée pour prendre date y compris
quelle que soit la décision qui sera
prise
ici maintenant et dans la suite de
l'élaboration de ce de ce texte car tout
cela je crois dans les périodes qui sont
qui sont présentes
ça a été dit temps d'état d'urgence
sont succédé et à chaque fois c'est
telle ou telle mesure qui semblait
tellement exceptionnel à chaque fois
qu'ils finissent par entrer dans la
réalité quotidienne
le débat est essentiel pour moi
maintenant ce sera non très bien la
parole est à madame de la gontrie
merci monsieur le président sur ces
amendements de suppression de l'article
à notre groupe a décidé de s'abstenir
pourquoi cet article est protéiforme
il contient à la fois des dispositions
sur le pass sanitaires effectivement et
je vais y revenir mais aussi un certain
nombre de dispositions qui entre qui
encadre de manière relative on aurait pu
souhaiter davantage les pouvoirs du
gouvernement la commission des lois a
d'ores et déjà procédé à un certain
nombre d'améliorations qui rejoignait
parfois les nôtres et nous les
soutiendrons
mais concernant le pass sanitaires nous
avons posé un certain nombre de demandes
est au fond c'est extrêmement simple et
même si je dirais aux ministres cedrico
que je l' ai entendu devant l'assemblée
nationale dire en une question sur le
pass sanitaires et la cnil que la cnil
n'avait rien à voir avec cela
nous reprenons l'intégralité des
préconisations de la cnil et c'est en ce
sens que nous demandons par amendement
qu'une jauge soit prévue de manière à ce
que les gens sachent dans quelle
circonstance ils devront avoir recours à
ce pas ce que nous demandons que les
types d'établissements concernés soit
inscrit dans la loi de manière à ce que
les exploitants sache à quel régime
ils vont devoir se plier et que
l'évaluation de ce dispositif soit faite
afin que nous sachions nous si ce que
nous avons voté est utile alors nous
avons déposé ces amendements
nous souhaitons que la discussion ait
lieu tout ça s'est fait dans des
conditions de délais extrêmement
précipitée et donc nous ne désespérons
pas de la qualité de débats et peut-être
de l'approbation d'un certain nombre de
nos propositions et je lui indique
d'ores et déjà si ses amendements
n'étaient pas acceptées nous serons
amenés au moment du vote sur l'ensemble
de l'arctique loin d'être défavorable à
cet article
et bien la parole est à madame benbassa
merci monsieur le président moi je
présente ici là la partie qui est contre
la suppression de cet article
ces amendements ont pas du pass et pour
ceux qui s'abstiennent
parce que c'est vrai que pour le moment
68% des français ont décidé enfin ont
demandé que le pass soit adopté et on
n'a pas d'autres
d'autres choses d'autres solutions à
proposer
c'est vrai qu'il doit avant tout s'agir
d'une mesure temporaire de gestion de
sortie de crise et nous ne pouvons pas
concevoir une utilisation
le ce dispositif au delà d'une période
où la france sera largement déployé sa
politique vaccinale est atteint
l'immunité collective sur son territoire
quels lieux seront concernés exactement
par la mise en place de ce pass et
malgré les précisions de la commission
les contours de la nasse de la notion de
grands rassemblements de personnes sont
encore trop flou dans la version
actuelle du texte
et puis bien sûr il convient de définir
clairement une jauge en dessous de
laquelle la présentation de ce pass ne
soit pas obligatoire
merci merci les deux ministres ayant
demandé la pole je leur propose une
panda vol qu'à la fin du parcours des
orateurs la parole est à monsieur chasse
un président les ministres mes chers
collègues
moi je vais être tout à fait bref ce
président je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit le président retailleau
et je suis aussi tout à fait d'accord
avec le président philippe bas
actuellement on a un virus qui encore
fait des décès on a près de 5 me un an
plus tôt plus de 4000 personnes en
réanimation
il faut être très très vigilant
la liberté c'est aussi d'aller dans une
manifestation et de ne pas être
contaminé la liberté aussi c'est pour
cela qu'on va faire des visites en ehpad
par exemple c'est pas contaminer les
ehpad donc je pense que nous devons être
très vigilants et je bien sûr avec
certains critères comme la le dit le
rapporteur philippe bas je pense que
nous devons accepter ce pass sanitaires
bien sûr pas tout le temps mais un
certain temps les vaccinations comme l'a
dit laurent duplomb vont s'accélérer
parce qu'on a des vaccins failli soeurs
qui ont dans une qui vont être mises en
place dans une nouvelle forme où on
pourra les garder avec des températures
autour d'eux dans un frigo réfrigérateur
normal donc on va ça va s'accélérer mais
pour l'instant il faut être très
vigilant
donc je ne voterai contre les
amendements merci je vais donner la
parole aux mini ci a pas d'autres
demandent à loïc hergé
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres collègue monsieur leur
apportant ce n'est pas de votre faute si
l'article premier comporte autant de
l'information il encore pas il en
comprend tellement d'ailleurs que en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
il ne comportait même pas le pass
sanitaires et le passage du ter il était
dans un texte qui est toujours déposer
sur le bureau de l'assemblée nationale
qui était déposée au mois de décembre
l'année dernière et qui en gros
reprenait à peu près les termes de
l'amendement qui a été adopté à
l'assemblée d'attirer je rappelle à nos
chers collègues que la semaine dernière
l'assemblée nationale ah ah ah non il
n'a pas voté les amendements de
suppression a examiné l'article premier
à intégrer deux passes anitea n'a pas
voté l'article 1er dans une première
lecture et que à la demande du
gouvernement une seconde délibération
élu et que à ce moment là dans des dans
des conditions que sur lesquels je n'en
reviens pas l'article premier a été
adopté dans la rédaction qui nous a été
soumise avant que nous l'examinions
commission il reçoit donc ça c'est quand
même important parce que le pass and
iter est arrivé un seul alinéa hier 7
désormais par voie d'amendement
deuxièmement le présent la république a
pris l'engagement qu'il n'y ait aucune
contrepartie à la vaccination et pardon
de ce présent retailleau mais la
vaccination n'est pas obligatoire contre
lacko vide ni pour les adultes ni pour
les enfants elle l'est dans les écoles
par la loi elle est la vaccination à
l'agglo à partir du moment et je suis
pro vais et je suis pour la vaccination
à titre personnel je suis pour la
vaccination mais j'estime que ma du mois
le vaccin n'est pas obligatoire et qu'il
n'y a pas de contrepartie à la
vaccination on est déjà à partir du
on instaure le passe à lithaire dans la
loi française dans une forme de
contrepartie à la vaccination
enfin sur la question d'aider des jauges
faudra nous expliquer comment un
événement culturel peut se tenir dans
une salle à 999 s'en passe sanitaires et
à partir de 1000 travailleurs à 1001
nécessité qu'on met en place tout un
dispositif de contrôle de la santé et
c'est pour ça que effectivement votre
rédaction de ce rapporteur est bien
meilleure que celle de l'assemblée
nationale enfin mes chers collègues je
voudrais vous avez su a sans doute reçu
des centaines de mails de gens vous
souvent des chaînes vous demandant de ne
pas voter ce thème moyens parmi ces
mails a un qui n'est pas une chaîne qui
est une personne handicapée qui m'a
écrit qu'elle crée un certain nombre
d'entre vous c'est une personne qui
n'aurait pas eu d'accidents qu'il peut
pas subir de test pcr et même si elle
respecte tous les gestes barrière cette
personne ne pourra pas avoir accès aux
différents événements que nous lui
interdirions de fait c'est je vous mets
en garde mes chers collègues à partir du
moment où nos roseaux ce type là nous
aurons des difficultés de mise en oeuvre
extrêmement concrètes parce que le qr
code ne marchera pas parce que telle
personne ne pourra pas présenter les
justificatifs qui sont exigés et nous
devons nous aurons une rupture d'égalité
considérable très bien aller j'ai un
dernier par pitié si vous avez si vous
êtes en manque
n'hésitez pas à lever la main avant je
donne la parole au ministre non il n'a
pas d'autres monsieur rallier merci
monsieur le président l'amendement que
je devais défendre juste après les trois
qu'ils sont présentés ici tout de suite
s'inscrivait dans une sorte de compromis
il proposait un régime transitoire
jusqu'au 15 juillet pour surveiller
l'évolution de l'épidémie on finit avec
l'état d'urgence de juin et interdire le
pass sanitaires et jeudi un amendement
que je
vais défendre car il semblerait que mon
appel au courage parlementaire et été
entendu par un certain nombre de nos
chers collègues de droite pas tous à
tous le président retailleau ayant
préféré abondé dans le sens du
gouvernement mais j'entends et j'ai
entendu un certain nombre de sénateurs
de droite et sénateurs il faut il faut
il faut il faut un certain courage que
certains que certains rappelleront quand
même une nouvelle erreur une nouvelle
faute et bien tous sur les bancs de
droite ne sont pas de cet avis et
préfère dénoncer une mesure liberticide
qui n'est pas impliquée par 1 1
comment dirais-je un parti extrémiste
parce que j'ai entendu un à nos
collègues envisagé comme partis
extrémistes pourraient se servir de ces
mesures
voter aujourd'hui pour les durcir
davantage demain nous n'avons pas besoin
de partis extrémistes nous avons déjà le
gouvernement qui a saisi qui a saisi
cette crise sanitaire pour créer une
crise démocratique
voilà un an que le parlement est méprisé
que le gouvernement le président en
réalité agisse seul
eh bien nous avons l'opportunité mes
chers collègues de mettre un coup
d'arrêt à cette dérive autoritaire à 7
et à ses dérives extrémistes
alors je vous invite pour celles et ceux
qui n'auront qui hésiteraient encore et
bien à faire preuve de courage et à vous
opposer à cette dérive en soutenant
comme je le ferais ces trois amendements
à tout hasard monsieur ravi vous retirer
pas l'amendement suivant
non j'ai essayé de faire ce que je
pouvais aller maintenant au gouvernement
alors je sais pas dans quelle mesure
vous en prie mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs j'ai eu l'occasion il ya
quelques moi de me prononcer à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat sur la
question du pass sanitaires et j'avais
dit en abandon vieux débat que nous
avons là que je comprenais que ce soit
un sujet de forte sensibilité qui nous
interrogent qui nous interpellent et
dont la réponse ne soit pas évidente
j'avais d'ailleurs j'étais allé un cran
plus loin en disant avant même de
connaître le contenu d'un texte de loi
je m'étais entre quelques en quelque
sorte mouillé 11 ans qu'à titre
personnel je ne serai pas favorable à ce
que dans notre pays on soit amené un
jour à exiger de montrer un test ou une
vaccination pour rentrer dans un
restaurant ou dans des lieux entre
guillemets la vie quotidienne tous les
français ne vont pas au quotidien au
restaurant évidemment mais pour des
actes de plus courant que d acte
exceptionnel
donc je me retrouve dans une partie des
je dirais des doutes qui ont pu être
émis ici c'est vraiment avec humilité
que je vous dis pour commencer ma
conviction s'est forgé s'agissant de la
version qui a été proposée par le
gouvernement
nous ne parlons pas là de lieux de la
vie courante
nous nous parlons là que de situations
qui ont un caractère exceptionnel
nous parlons là d'événements qui cumule
un certain nombre de facteurs d'abord
une population assez importante
on a parlé on a évoqué le seuil de 1000
personnes au minimum pour appliquer un
pass à lithaire on n'est pas tous les
jours dans notre vie en contact direct
avec nous plusieurs milliers de
personnes en tout cas plus de 1000
personnes
ensuite ça concerne des lieux qui par
définition vont associer un brassage de
population assez important par le
caractère exceptionnel la fréquentation
de ces lieux
quand on parle d'un grand salon prenons
un salon je ne sais pas ça non
automobiles ont un salon du vin par
exemple il y en a dans beaucoup de
territoires qui sont programmés par
avance des salons des vins
si vous avez la plus de 1000 personnes
que vous avez un brassage avec des gens
qui viennent de différents départements
différentes régions vous êtes là dans
des sites sûrs d'eux est là dans des
situations qui sont potentiellement à
risque de transmission du virus parce
qu'une personne ou cinq personnes ou 10
personnes si elles sont potentiellement
contagieuse peuvent vont contaminer
beaucoup d'autres si vous deviez être
convaincu de cela
regardez ce qui s'est passé en france au
cours des 15 mois écoulé et regardons ce
qui s'est passé à l'étranger le plus
gros exemple que nous ayons c'est ce
grand rassemblement ce festival outdoor
de motards aux états unis je crois que
j'étais dans le dakota gpu dans quel
état c'est eh oui quatre cent mille
personnes et elle a rassemblé avec un
grand brassage de population et il ya eu
250 milles contamination estimé suite à
cet événement
l'année dernière nous avons eu
l'occasion de débattre à de multiples
reprises des conditions d'ouverture de
jauge d l'anc ont commencé à dépasser un
certain nombre de deux personnes qui
avaient fréquenté des événements ou
souvenez sans doute des débats que nous
avions eues et moi j'étais plutôt sur la
de frein en vous disant on peut
pas avoir trop de personnes on peut pas
directement ouvrir des événements qui
vont rassembler des milliers de
personnes c'est pas raisonnable
la situation n'a pas changé et il ya en
plus des variants par rapport à l'année
dernière qui nous oblige encore à des
mesures de précaution ce que nous
n'avions pas l'année dernière et que
nous avons cette année c'est la
possibilité de minimiser au maximum les
risques et de faire en sorte que lorsque
des foules compactes se rassemblent dans
des lieux clos rassemblant beaucoup de
gens ou dans des lieux extérieurs mais
on peut être très en contact les uns
avec les autres
on peut s'assurer que les personnes
peuvent y aller en toute quiétude en
toute tranquillité sans avoir la peur
d'être potentiellement contact de
quelqu'un qui est contagieux il s'agit
pas de fliquer les gens il s'agit pas de
montrer un pedigree il s'agit
certainement pas d'installer dans la
durée la nécessité de montrer qu'on est
protégée contre le virus
il s'agit vraiment de permettre de
rouvrir des éléments qui sinon ne
pourrait pas être ouvrir dans ces mêmes
des conditions et je vous je vous invite
à regarder dans les différents
départements le nombre d'événements qui
pourront se tenir parce que le passe à
dix terre et qu'ils ne pourraient pas se
tenir
s'il n'y avait pas le passé ni terre
donc c'est pas du donnant-donnant ou un
chantage en quoi que ce soit c'est des
conditions de sécurité sanitaire qui
sont vraies
qui nous permettent de faire ce que
l'année dernière nous ne pouvions pas
faire alors même que vous nous le
demande y est les conditions pour
entraîner c'est pas que la vaccination
c'est un test qui est négatif depuis
moins de 48 heures et c'est pas un test
sérologique j'ai entendu un sénateur
tout à leur dire que la sérologie ne
servait pas jusqu'à présent pleinement
elle servirait sur sénateurs aujourd'hui
la sérologie ne peut pas être considéré
comme un argument pour pouvoir être
protégés contre le coc vide et c'est
donc un test de ce qu'on demande c'est
un certificat de rétablissement c'est à
dire la preuve qu'un test pcr était
positif
il n'y a plus de deux semaines et il ya
moins de six mois c'est ça que nous
demandons est en définitive la question
qui se pose sur la vaccination la
vaccination
nous vaccinons de plus en plus vite de
plus en plus forts 20 millions de primo
vaccination 30 millions bientôt et c'est
à ces vaccins sont gratuits sont
proposés la population et vous verrez
dans quelques semaines nous devons
collectivement nous mobiliser pour
inciter les français qui hésitent encore
à se faire vacciner
on retournera l'objectif qui est
aujourd'hui de trouver le maximum de
créneaux possibles
demain ce sera trouvée d'identifier le
maximum de français pour se faire
vacciner
encore une fois avec la gratuité des
tests la gratuité des vaccins et c est
donc ce que nous vous demandons c'est de
ne pas imposer à quelqu'un qui est déjà
vaccinées de devoir réaliser un test
avant de rentrer dans un salon un espace
confiné
c'est de lui permettre de considérer
qu'il est libéré de cette obligation
tout est là pour pouvoir y rentrer donc
j'ai pas du tout hein
un chantage à la vaccination qui vous
est proposé enfin monsieur le sénateur
loïc hervé jeu je ne sais pas si
quelqu'un
quelqu'un peut effectivement dans des
rares très rares situations est contre
indiquée par la vaccination
je suis plus interpellé par l'idée que
quelqu'un puisse être contre indiquée
pour la réalisation de tests
diagnostiques
non mais je veux bien quelqu'un voulait
écrire je remet pas du tout en question
je réfléchis juste qu'il ne peut pas
avoir un test pcr un test anti génique
voir un test salivaire pourquoi pas si
vraiment la situation l'exigeait enfin
je ne vois pas dans quelle situation ça
peut se poser voilà donc mesdames et
messieurs
vous connaissez ma position et je suis
résolument favorable aux tests au pass
sanitaires dans les conditions qui vous
sont proposés on en fera aucun abus mais
ça va nous permettre de rouvrir plus
vite plus fort et de retrouver une vie
économique et sociale plus importante
merci la parole est à monsieur cédric oh
oui monsieur le président apporter juste
une précision sur la question des parcs
une précision technique puisque la
question a été abordée ce sujet a fait
l'objet de nombreux échanges avec les
responsables concernés je vous signale
madame la sénatrice que nous avons fait
évoluer ce que nous pensions faire
puisque les parcs d'attraction ou les
parcs à thème ne sont pas soumis aux
passes annie terre en tant que tel c'est
à dire que vous pouvez rentrer à euro
disney sans avoir à présenter votre pass
in ter
par contre et c'est vrai mais là en
cohérence avec ce que nous faisons par
ailleurs s'il y a un établissement
recevant du public donc une salle à
l'intérieur du parc
avec plus de mille personnes ce qui
correspond à certains cas mais qui sont
quand même relativement limité alors
dans ce cas l'accès à cette saab est
soumis aux pasteurs ce qui est un
équilibre qui nous a semblé le plus
logique compte tenu de ce que nous
décidions par ailleurs mais qui permet
aux parcs à thème j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'entretenir avec fière de pouvoir
rouvrir sans avoir tous les
inconvénients évoqué qui nous semble le
meilleur équilibre possible
très bien je vous rappelle que j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe l'est républicain sur les
amendements 15 16 et 67
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable
l'avis du gouvernement est défavorable
qui le résultat du scrutin numéro 120
sur les amendements identiques 1 16 67
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de votes
344 nombre de suffrages exprimés 265
pour l'adoption des trois amendements de
43 contre 222
le sénat n'a pas adopté et je passe en
conséquence à l'amendement 96 de
monsieur ravier comme j'aurais aimé vous
épargner de minutes d'intervention sur
président du cher collègue mais bon le
courage a manqué quand même beaucoup de
monde tant pis mes chers collègues le
régime de sortie de l'état d'urgence
devrait selon le texte du gouvernement
s'appliquer jusqu'au 31 octobre 2021
cet amendement vise à raccourcir ce
délai au 15 juillet 2021
cela laisse un mois et demi au
gouvernement pour organiser une sortie
de l'état d'urgence progressive
cet amendement prévoit également de
réécrire l'article 1er enfin de
supprimer toutes dispositions visant à
imposer le pass sanitaires après de
longs mois difficiles pour les français
la crise sanitaire semble enfin se
calmer et cela non pas grâce aux mesures
restrictives du gouvernement mais grâce
à l'avancée de la vaccination
la décrue des cas de coronavirus et la
baisse de la pression sur les services
hospitaliers s'observe dans tous les
pays européens la france faisant partie
des retardataires en début d'année 2021
la fameuse étude de l'institut
australien lowy avait estimé que notre
pays se trouvait 73e au classement des
pays qui avait le mieux géré la crise du
coc vide
mvié mauvais classement puisque
l'organisme indépendant a évalué en tout
80 18 pays depuis un nouveau confinement
la fermeture des commerces et le
maintien du couvre feu non par dresser
un bilan qui restera dans sa globalité
catastrophique
désormais le gouvernement des plus dans
l'urgence et doit maintenant travailler
de concert avec le parlement pour gérer
la sortie de crise en supprimant
largement les pouvoirs des représentants
du peuple pour les concentrés dans les
mains de l'exécutif
votre politique mais la démocratie comme
j'ai déjà pu le dire en grand danger
le couvre-feu ainsi que les fermetures
et restrictions arbitraires doivent
prendre fin au plus tôt la possibilité
de suspendre un certain nombre de
libertés jusqu'au 31 octobre ne se
justifie plus vous pérenniser ainsi la
suppression de nos libertés cerise sur
le gâteau d'une série d'erreurs
et de revirements la mise en place
donnent pas sanitaire va à l'encontre
non seulement des précédents
l'engagement du gouvernement mais aussi
de l'égalité entre les citoyens de notre
pays
l'article le premier tel qu'il est pour
l'instant écrit prévoit en effet de
restreindre un certain nombre
d'activités aux seules personnes
disposant d'un poste sanitaire
le gouvernement propose la droite
sénatoriale approuve dans sa grande
majorité
l'amt un dispositif n'est pas nécessaire
et mettant en péril les valeurs prônées
par le triptyque républicain
nous devons absolument refuser de nous
habituer à ces mesures liberticides
même si l'on sait qu'il n'ya plus de
ligne politique claire sheller j invite
tous les sénateurs en leur proposant une
seconde chance et qu'ils se sentent
encore en opposition à ce gouvernement a
voté cet amendement afin de ne pas
commettre une nouvelle faute et une
nouvelle erreur un par nola
impardonnable elle aussi pour nos
compatriotes bien à vis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis est défavorable monsieur le
président parce que cet amendement
supprime tout instrument de lutte contre
l'épidémie à partir du 15 juillet
prochain moi je ne trouve pas ça
raisonnable
chacun en pensera ce qu'il voudra mais
il me semble que ce serait prendre avec
la santé publique des risques énormes et
que la responsabilité est plutôt dans le
sens de matières des moyens d'action qui
permettent d'éviter une nouvelle flambée
de l'épidémie on serait tous bien
malheureux y compris l'auteur de
l'amendement certainement si cette
flambée survenait fautes qu'on ait
maintenu nos capacités d'action même
allée du gouvernement je mets aux voix
le 96 avec deux avis défavorables qui
est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté le 30 6 madame de la
gontrie
merci président c'est un amendement qui
a vocation à renforcer le contrôle
parlementaire du régime de sortie d'état
d'urgence puisque il ya déjà un certain
nombre d'informations qui sont
transmises à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat mais ici ce n'est pas prévu de
manière précise et donc nous souhaitons
que ce soit indiqué dans le texte
merci avis du rapporteur il est
défavorable
déjà 20 à vis du gouvernement il sera un
avis défavorable
je me mets aux voileux 36 avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pur il est rejeté
le 50 monsieur le ministre
le 50 cm si l'amendement du gouvernement
monsieur merci monsieur le président un
amendement qui vise à préciser
l'applicabilité du régime de sanctions
prévues par l'article l 31-36 pardon 1-1
dispositions de l'article 1er de ce
présent projet de loi amendement
explicite donc pour chaque catégorie de
mesures susceptibles d'être prises
pendant la période de mise en oeuvre du
régime de sortie les conditions dans
lesquelles sont constatées et réprimer
les infractions à ces mesures en
référence aux conditions applicables aux
catégories de mesures analogues prises
dans le cadre de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
cet amendement soumet par ailleurs
expressément le constat et la répression
des infractions à l'interdiction de mise
en place d'un pass sanitaire hors des
cas prévus par la loi au cadre prévu par
l'article l 31 36 1 que je citais tout à
l'heure en matière d'ouverture des
établissements recevant du public voilà
monsieur le président l'objet de cet
amendement du gouvernement
merci avis la commission sur le
rapporteur défavorable défavorable sur
cet amendement du gouvernement un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour et qui est contre
s'il est rejeté et chaque collègue je
suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public sur l'article 1er par les groupes
les républicains ils vont observer
fait de donner les explications de vote
mais je demande à chaque gros de bien
vouloir se préparer au scrutin public
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
votez vous rappelle que vous votez sur
l'approbation de l'article et non plus
sur un amendement
voici le résultat du scrutin 121 sur
l'article un contenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 344 nombre de suffrages exprimés
330 pour l'adoption 221 contre 109
le sénat a adopté
[Musique]